so we begin in Russia where it's emerged
at the funeral of wagon and chief
yevgenie pragosan has been held his
press service said the precaution was
buried in a private ceremony outside his
home city of Saint Petersburg Kremlin
said President Vladimir Putin would not
attend the funeral of his former Ally
Services were also held for other
leaders of the mercenary group who the
Kremlin says were killed in a plane
crash last Wednesday they included a
Valerie at chekolov Wagner's head of
logistics it's across straight away to
Julia who's live for us in Moscow so
Yulia tell us more what we know of
precautions funeral
well you know so much speculation about
the place and the time of his funeral
and now we've got reports that uh
actually the funeral took place and
according to the wishes of his relatives
uh that was a A Farewell a close very
far farewell ceremony to progression it
was held in a closed format in Saint
Petersburg and only his closest friends
and family were present around 40 people
were present that uh the Press service
of preggers invited all those wishing to
say goodbye and a bid their farewell to
visit porohov School Cemetery in Saint
Petersburg and that makes us presume
that progression was buried there the
borohov school Cemetery uh and uh there
his father is also buried
um as he had the title of the hero of
Russia he was supposed to be buried with
military honors but we understand that
none of that actually happened and
Julia why do you think the funeral has
been kept out of the public eye to the
degree that it has
well it seems like the authorities
wanted to avoid uh people to get
together in large numbers uh in one
place it seems like uh the the
authorities tried hard to keep
progressions funerals low-key and uh
earlier we saw some kind of activity in
other cemeteries in Saint Petersburg to
kind of treat his supporters as really
very many people wanted to get together
to say goodbye to uh to pregosian to the
Wagner leader and obviously we
understand that all those people who
actually crashed in that plane crash
last week they are presumed to be buried
in different places to avoid crowds of
people getting together and as you
mentioned President Putin wasn't present
at the pregosian funeral at the
pregosian burial ceremony as well
thanks for that
let's take this on we can speak to Jack
maglin he has extensively monitored
private military companies is currently
writing book on the Wagner group joins
us live now from Washington D.C Jack
thanks for joining us now uh in reality
it's no surprise that this was done
without any fanfare
not really no um I mean I think we've
seen already that the Russian state has
had to navigate a very uncomfortable
line here Putin referring to pagosian as
a very successful businessman
um who's made some really meaningful
sacrifices for the Russian state but
someone who made mistakes in his life
um I think similarly this lets them
avoid having to confront more publicly
the issues around pagosian and his
service to Putin had it been a you know
well-publicized funeral would it have
been
extremely popular and widely attended
I think so there's a sort of cult of
Wagner within Russia
um we've seen recently ceremonies in
Memorial to pagosian which the Russian
State I think has been very intentional
and not shutting down and those have
been pretty widely attended as well as
car rallies that happened even before
his death so there's quite a large
following of not just former Fighters
but also folks that admire the Wagner
group and what they represent for this
Resurgence of Russian nationalism
so what now about pagosian's Legacy and
what kind of problem that presents for
Vladimir Putin
so first of all there's the obvious uh
issue the fact that fregoian represents
the the ability of Russian Elites to uh
coerce the Russian State into extracting
concessions right so by directly
threatening uh the Russian State you
might be able to survive at least for a
time
um we can also see that the Russian
State doesn't have many much recourse to
deal with problems like this except
through violence and then finally
there's the issue of Wagner itself right
um the Russian state is in no hurry to
get rid of this uh this Force which has
benefited them in in Africa and in
Ukraine but at the same time I think
they're going to find it very very
difficult to take this Mass a very
experienced Fighters what has been in
many ways an effective force and either
integrate that with the Russian armed
forces or fold it into one of the
existing private military companies
which are in fact controlled by Russian
military intelligence could it indeed
operate under the command of the
ministry of Defense
I think they're likely to try I think
that what they'll encounter quite
quickly is that a large part of Wagner's
competitive Advantage was unique factors
of its structure the degree of arms that
it had the scale that it had and it
simply is not going to have the trust to
enjoy those types of benefits anymore on
top of that if you don't have a curator
like pregosian
um then individual fighting units aren't
going to have the same level of autonomy
in the field which we really saw in
places like bakmud uh where Wagner was
able to apply tactics and be reactive in
ways that the Russian military was
really struggling to do elsewhere in the
war in Ukraine could it as a force
become any kind of threat to Putin
I think that's pretty unlikely at this
point there's not a great succession
plan here there's no one who's really
well placed to take over Wagner and I
think it's very significant that we
haven't seen any statements from the
Council of commanders of Wagner since
pregosian's death so they who have
recently kind of come out of the Shadows
have been more outspoken representing
the group have been very intentional and
not making comments and not conjecturing
about Putin's death other sectors of
sort of the Russian far-right and
ultra-nationalist circles have been
pretty outspoken in their criticism of
the handling of pregosian in general but
Wagner commanders in general they've
seemed to have remained much more quiet
about this and are taking a more
cautious line
all right Jake thanks for that Jack
marglin speaking to us there from
Washington DC
thank you